hello
and welcome to a simply learn webinar
beyond the textbook decision analytic
principles for data scientists
our guest today is brad powley from
salesforce
more about him in a minute
and what we will do now is share with
you a few
instructions for how to interact with us
during the webinar
so we have a q a button which is the
square with the question mark
if you don't see that the three dots
will get you there
and if you enter your question it will
be logged
for the q a period of the webinar at the
end of the session
also we'll be asking you to interact
with us with chat
which is the speech bubble button please
set your setting to all panelists
and ask all panelists um
your chat questions there will be a
couple of times when brad asks you to do
this specifically
so that he can look at a couple of those
live
and with that i will introduce brad
welcome brad thank you stuart
and thank you to simply learn for this
opportunity uh
just let me say a few words about myself
before we get started
i work at salesforce uh on a team of
machine learning engineers
and our team works on data products
for delivering insights to customers uh
we use like i said machine learning
quite a bit
and distributed data processing uh but i
haven't always worked
in this field before during joining
salesforce
i worked in strategy consulting i worked
for a boutique firm called
strategic decisions group um and in that
firm i helped clients make kind of high
stakes decisions
across industries energy life sciences
real estate
i.t manufacturing et cetera before that
i was an engineer
and so my engineering experience is also
quite
diverse from mechanical design to
manufacturing
systems engineering and then finally
software development
in the middle of all that i got a phd
and my
research in my studies focused on a
field called decision analysis
and i'm particularly interested in
decision making and its intersection
with
artificial intelligence okay so before
we get started
i have a compulsory slide
to show you uh from my employer and
among other things what it's saying is
don't make investment decisions
solely based on what you see in this
particular presentation
and uh there are more details here as
well
but this is just a forward-looking
statement
okay so before we get started um
it's really important to me that we
define a handful
of distinctions um
the first uh set of distinctions is
uh related to uh data and i
i think this is important particularly
important because
uh but my this is very important to my
phd advisor i should say
that we want to distinguish ambiguity
from uncertainty because uncertainty is
really important in decision making
and we don't want ambiguity around
definitions to impinge on that
uncertainty we don't want to add
our uncertainty um it looks like we have
some questions
stuart uh i wonder if i can mute my chat
um if you could hold yeah
you should be able to just close the
chat window for the time being
okay it's sending notifications anyway
so let's work through these definitions
so the first definition
uh relates to data so unless otherwise
stated
when i'm talking about data i'm talking
about the recorded facts that a person
uses to make predictions
i'm not talking about for the purpose of
entertainment or nostalgia
or record keeping etc so for example um
when i talk about data i'm not talking
about the information
uh you know in your data plan for
example
i'm talking about data in the context of
prediction
when i talk about data product i'm
talking about an application
that uses data to make predictions so an
example of this
might be a gmail so with gmail
uh there's a product that classifies
your inbox
into three different categories primary
uh social and promotional and basically
it's taking information from your emails
and predicting
how you would classify it and putting
the emails in those various buckets okay
so that's an example of a data product
another example of a data product might
be a lane keeping feature
in a an automobile okay
and then data science so this is just to
me i like to cast a wide tent here
this is just a discipline of deriving
meaning from data
uh the fourth definition i'd like to
talk about this is perhaps the most
important one is is that of a decision
so i talk about a decision i'm talking
about an irrevocable allocation of
resources
i'm not talking about an expression of
intent
so what i mean by that is it's not a
decision to say
i'm going to go buy a car today
the decision happens when you write the
check and hand it over
okay so it's not an expression of intent
it's an allocation of resources it's an
action
the fifth item is decision analysis and
this is a field that helps decision
makers achieve clarity of action so
one thing that's really difficult with
decisions is knowing what to do
and this is one field that helps people
know what to do when they're faced with
a decision
and then finally i'll mention the
decision professional occasionally and
this is just somebody who practices
decision analysis
okay so a word about decision analysis
it's a field that's existed for about 50
years
it was developed by howard rafa at
harvard university
and ronald a howard at stanford
university
the latter of whom was my phd advisor
okay so now that we have sort of a
common understanding of these
key definitions let's move forward and
motivate this talk
so there's evidence that
companies that are able to extract value
from data
are the companies that are the most
valuable okay so
this infographic is particularly telling
what it shows
is various uh snapshots
of the top 10 valued companies in the us
by market capitalization okay so it
starts in 1917
if you look at the companies uh they're
largely commodities companies natural
resources companies like standard oil
u.s steel
u.s rubber et cetera you fast forward 50
years
and you begin to see more finished goods
companies like general motors consumer
products eastman kodak etc
there's a little bit of uh encroachment
from
data companies for example ibm shows up
at the top of the list
but companies that extract value from
data do not dominate this list
but then you look 50 years into the
future and now the dominance
shows right so we have apple alphabet
which is google's parent company
microsoft amazon and facebook being the
top five
out of the list of ten and you might say
well that's just the us
so i looked to get some information
globally
of market capitalization and it largely
tells the same story
outside of saudi aramco which topped the
list in 2019
we have the same five companies from the
us and add to that
two more data focus companies alibaba
group and 10
cent and so the list even looks more
dominant by data-driven companies
okay so you might think okay well that's
that's looking into the past like what
what are the trends well
it just so happens that the
storage of data the capacity to store
data has been growing at an exponential
rate
and if we look at this chart what we see
it plots the number of bytes
of global data storage against time
okay so uh you can ignore the blue
and green curves and just look at the
gray curve which is the sum of those two
and what this shows and by the way the
y-axis is a log plot so each tick on
this y-axis is 10 times more than the
previous tick
what it shows is that there's
exponential growth
in the storage of data and in fact it's
30
30 year-over-year growth and
if you think about that a corollary of
that statement is
that if you look at the final three
years and this is a snapshot in time
from a little bit
you know about five years ago and this
is from
research done by uh professor martin
hilbert at uc davis
if you look just at the years 2012
through 2014
as much new data storage capacity went
online in those three years as existed
in previous human history
think about that for a minute the amount
of data that
a storage capacity for data is growing
at a rapid rate the only reason it grows
at that rate
is because we have need for it to grow
at that rate so
the point is is that data has been
important
it will continue to be important it
looks to be that way and
those who understand how to extract that
value from it will be
at an advantage okay
so if you look at the popular business
literature
um you see largely the same story so
uh here's a quote from bcg insights who
is a major consultancy
in the u.s and it says over the past few
years
it has been established as a fundamental
source of business value
okay so they're seeing the same trends
and you look okay add an hbr
article harvard business review and they
say the most valuable and powerful
businesses for the foreseeable future
will be those that are built both on
regular network effects
and enhanced by data enabled learning
okay so another
case for data being important and then
finally
and this is perhaps the strongest
statement from a mckinsey report
which is also a major consultancy in the
u.s and they say
data has become the new corporate asset
class this is amazing
a new corporate asset class you have
stocks bonds
uh commodities and data i mean this is a
this is a major statement and so
now i'd like to turn it over to you
and so if you could open your chat
windows and answer this question just in
free text
what gives data its value
so take a moment and answer that
question please
give your opinion on that
here we have one uh from from rajneesh
sharma
he says how can it be analyzed and used
from analysis from me to good
power to transform business the way it
is used
visualization insights that can be
derived from it from rahul
it's very nice
yeah very good okay let's wrap up
our answers um i'll give you a couple
more seconds to send your final
thoughts and then we'll move on
there lies business values inside it
this is great okay
so these there are many excellent
answers here
prediction easily referenceable really
good
okay so let's go back to the experts
from that business literature
and see what they say
so from the mit sloan review
uh gandhi and his and his co-authors
uh last year say this they say data on
its own has value
but insights derived from data
substantially increase that value
we heard some thoughts similar to this
in the chat window
very good okay so that's what they say
let's move on to the next one
this is from the mckinsey report it says
data in its raw and most basic form
is virtually worthless okay that's
already in conflict with the mit sloan
report
it's saying data on its own has value
but then they go on to say until we give
it a voice by gleaning valuable insights
from it okay so now there's some
agreement
so let's look at the final example and
this one
is from a pwc report another consultancy
in the u.s
and they say the value of data be that
yours or of others
ultimately lies in its usefulness in
achieving your strategic goals
okay so there's a lot here and there's a
lot here that's
that overlaps nicely with what uh people
answered and i don't have
major argument with any of this but i
don't also don't think it gets to the
root
of the question so what is the root of
the question
so here's my argument in the context of
prediction
decisions are what give value to data
and how can we think about this let's
think about a data value chain
okay so we start with data itself and
as someone uh wrote into the chat window
data enable predictions
so we think that's true okay so with
with data we can make predictions
and with predictions we can help people
make better decisions because oftentimes
the thing that stands in the way of a
good decision
is uncertainty and predictions can help
reduce uncertainty
and decisions themselves are the way
that make
better futures for themselves right this
is how people can change their future
and in other words uh if if i'm
going along on sort of a momentum status
quo sort of a trajectory
and i don't change anything my future
has a certain amount
of value to me if i want to change it
i have to make a decision i have to take
an action okay
so given all of this
my argument is is that data scientists
should not only become experts
in handling data visualizing data etc
they should also have a certain amount
of expertise in decision making
because decisions are where the source
of the value of data is from
okay so
let's talk about a few decision analytic
principles i introduced this field of
decision analysis
early on and for me the precepts in this
field
are the best way that i know of
uh to develop expertise in decision
making to make better decisions
okay so i'll call this some old wisdom
from a new field
or for a new field excuse me
okay so here's the first um principle
decisions are the way that we change our
future so we just talked about that
so if we want a different future if we
want a future that's
of higher value we need to make
decisions
the second one and this is super
important when uncertainty is involved
okay when uncertainty is involved you
cannot determine the quality of a
decision by the quality of its outcome
okay so you cannot determine the quality
of a decision
by the quality of its outcome and there
are a couple of corollaries to this
one is a good decision never turns bad
and a bad decision never turns good and
there's a lot to unpack here so let me
just uh elucidate this a little bit
by giving an example imagine you're a
parent
and you have a son and this son is going
out with friends and this son finds
himself
at a party with his friends and the
people at the party are drinking
and the friend who is driving your son
has drunk too much and really should not
drive
because it would be dangerous so now
your son faces a decision
he can get in the car and be driven home
by his drunk friend or
he can call you and have you come and
pick him up
okay so i think most people would agree
that the good decision is to call that
he should call you
for a ride and not come home with his
drunk friend
okay but suppose that he decides to go
with his drunk friend
and by happy circumstance they make it
home safely
does that now make his decision a good
decision of course not
right and likewise if he had called you
to come pick him up and you had gotten
into a car accident on the way to pick
him up
would that have been a bad decision and
again the answer is no
so a good decision never turns bad and a
bad decision never turns good
and most importantly we cannot determine
the quality of a decision by the quality
of its outcome
when uncertainty is involved okay so
given this
we can and must we should be able to
assess the quality of a decision
before it's made because you want to
make good decisions
it doesn't do you any good to look back
on it because you can't change it
what you want to be able to do is at the
time you're making that decision be able
to assess its quality
okay so how would you do that
well it turns out that there's a
framework for this and this was
developed
uh through decision practitioners back
in the 1980s
and the notion is that there's a
metaphor of a chain
and uh in the chain there are six
different
elements of decision quality okay and
the metaphor the chain is such that
your the quality of your decision is
only as strong as the qual
as the strength of its weakest land okay
so you need all these things to have a
high quality decision
so let's talk through the six and i
think this is a really nice framework to
use because it allows people to have
conversations
about whether a decision is good or not
before it's made
so the first item is the frame so
the frame of the decision is if i can
just distill it into a few words
it's the decision's purpose and it's
bounds
so what is it you're trying to do and
what are you deciding
and what are you not deciding right what
are you including as a possible
alternative and what are you excluding
and that's what i mean by balance
now the second item
is alternatives so alternatives are a
decision set of possible actions so
every decision consists of a set of
alternatives and these are the things we
could do
in the case of the example i gave with
the son at the party
his alternatives were twofold one he can
go
with his drunk friend or two he can call
his parents and get picked up
perhaps there's a third decision perhaps
he could have walked home perhaps
there's a fourth excuse me alternative
perhaps he could have called a taxi okay
so this is the set of alternatives the
things you can do
third we have information and this is
where data come into play
so this is the all the data experience
judgment etc
you can bring to bear in making the
decision okay that's the
information uh component next we'll go
to trade-offs
and trade-offs is a means for comparing
the value of different combinations of
competing factors
so there are lots of trade-offs that can
be facing decisions for policy makers it
can be a trade-off between
the amount of money you spend versus the
amount of safety
or the amount of lives you save in a in
a country for example
a classic engineering trade-off is
three-fold it's between
the cost of developing a product the
quality of that product
and the time it takes to develop that
product so that's like the three things
oftentimes
if you want to uh do better on two of
those three things you have to give up
on once in other words
if you want a product that has higher
quality and
you want it to not cost very much it may
take longer to develop
for example uh for a fifth we have
reasoning
and reasoning is just the logic it's how
you
choose an alternative based on the
information and trade-offs that you have
and the set of alternatives and then
finally there's commitment
and so if you've gone through the entire
process
you've gone through the reasoning it's
clear which alternative is best do you
really have commitment
uh to make the decision that you said
you're gonna make do you really mean it
okay so with these six things we can
evaluate
a decision so
once again a high quality decision
requires each element each of these six
elements to be of high quality
okay so let's go to a
poll and stuart if you could uh put the
poll question up so people could give
their answers to this multiple choice
question and the question is
if you work with data which presumably
many of you do
which of these six elements should you
focus on
so if you could click on your answer uh
and hit submit i'd appreciate that
and we'll just give about a minute for
people to
make their selection
once again as people are deciding the
frame is
um the bounds and the purpose for your
decision the alternatives are the things
you can do
the information are things like data and
experience and judgment that you bring
to bear on the decision
the trade-offs are how you
decide between competing values things
like
cost versus quality for example
reasoning is how you tie the whole thing
together the logic that you use and
finally
commitment is whether or not you're
willing to
make the investment once it's clear
which alternative is the best one to
choose
okay we have a set of results here and
it looks like the winner is information
and uh with the second place being
reasoning and i think those are
reasonable answers
okay so what i'm going to say
about this is my answer
is it depends it depends on what kind of
decision we're talking about
and we're gonna enter into a case study
here in a minute
and that'll show that'll give us a
chance to talk about different kinds of
decisions
and how they interact with data
scientists
and then given that um
uh which part of decision quality is the
one that you want to really focus on
okay so let's move forward in that in
that direction
so i want to get into this case study
before i do i want to talk a little bit
about salesforce
and many of you may know about
salesforce
some may not so just from a high level
uh salesforce is a software as a service
company
it's one of the original software as a
service companies uh it's been around
for about 20 years
and we are passionate about helping
our customers be successful and uh there
are various
different markets that we play in uh for
example we help with
uh cert the service market like service
calls things like that
marketing etc our bread and butter
is and historically has been the sales
market so
we help sales people uh sell products
and be coordinated and be organized
about selling their products
to their customers so we care not only
about our customers which are
organizations that have sales people but
we also care about our customers
customers the people that they're
selling to
and in this case study you'll see two
types of interactions mentioned and i
want to talk about those a little bit
just so you have context for them
uh one is that a sales person one of our
customers
who uses our product oftentimes may give
a sales
offer to one of their potential
customers and
their potential customer uh responds
with some
form of objection and that objection
might be something like we don't have
money now
or um that the timing isn't right can
you talk to us next quarter
or uh we just don't really need your
product or maybe you should talk to my
boss et cetera so this
this is a kind of thing in the sales
parlance called
an objection okay so that's one kind of
kind of interaction we'll talk about
the other one we'll talk about um
oftentimes
when sales people are working with an
existing account this is a company
they've already
sold to before who may be using one of
their products but they want to sell
an additional product to uh the customer
will
come back to them and with an issue for
that product like
hey you sold us your product and i'm
having problems with this particular
aspect of your product
and so the sales person oftentimes will
receive uh complaints about an existing
product
and so those are the two things we'll be
talking about in this case study
so let's move into the case study
okay so we have a product manager and
she's on the left
in the pink shirt and she approaches
your data science team and this is you
on the right in the plaid shirt
and she says we want to automatically
alert salespeople when their clients
send
angry emails and our customer research
shows that when a potential client is
angry
time is of the essence and we want this
to be available by the end of q3
and our data science leader says well
sentiment classification is a common
natural language processing task
we know what to do but we don't know
whether our data will support
this idea of an angry email classifier
but he says we'll look into the data
right away so
he goes off with his team to begin a
spike to see whether the available data
can support this idea
and so a week passes and he comes back
and he says
hey the spike yields mixed results we've
learned that business emails are very
polite
they're more polite than things like
tweets and product reviews
and after some quick prototypes our team
agrees that an angry email classifier
while possible would be difficult to get
right on the timeline of this project
and she says oh that's bad news to which
he responds
we did however notice there are two
types of emails with polite
but negative feedback the first is
objections to sales offers
and the second is issues with an
existing product
and then he asks an important question
he says are we working on the right
problem
and she says well let me check with our
user experience
research team about testing these two
ideas with customers
and so she goes off and talks to that
team to begin some studies
on the idea of automating the
classification of sales objection emails
and issues
and a week passes again and apparently
uh they wear the same clothes each week
or on that day each week uh and so she
comes back and she says good news
uh the research suggests that people
were excited about an automated system
for identifying and classifying sales
objections
and they weren't quite as excited about
classifying product issues
so he says you know we think we can
build an objection classifier we think
we can do that
and she says great i'll put that on our
product roadmap
so let's work out a plan to make it
successful so the scene the team decides
to pursue an email objection classifier
and now i have a question for you that
i would ask you to open the chat window
again and give your responses to
and we'll keep it open for about a
minute and here's my question poll
question number three
uh please enter via the chat window and
the question is
what could go wrong in this project so
presumably
uh may i just ask if you uh use
to everyone in this chat window other
people will be able to see
your responses i think we've had some
questions
from the audience about that so if you
use to everyone
uh to answer this question that would be
helpful thank you stuart
so presumably many of you have
had experience working on data projects
or have at least
been uh in the room when such decisions
are made
and so you have a sense for what might
go wrong and so the question is what do
you think might go wrong oops
uh this is nice just difficulties in
classifying mixed emotions
very good
yeah so we might have a technical
difficulty um
for example oftentimes uh when people
uh object to something they're
exceedingly polite they say oh thank you
very much but this the timing just isn't
right
right
now but we really enjoyed uh the demo
you gave us
it's really hard to extract an objection
from that but there is an objection
so there's another one difficulty in
classification
these are all technical technical
difficulties what about
difficulties organizationally what lots
of people have about that
inconsistencies in the data typos
underlying meanings yeah for sure
okay let's give this about 30 more
seconds um
type in what you think might go wrong
and we can talk more about that
ah the primary objective of the project
has changed
right and it did change
what is going to be done with the
insights later is not clear
lack of concepts one might say lack of
alternatives right
maybe the solution won't provide enough
business value
right that's good okay so let's
let's wrap this up these are really
great responses
and i think they're all reasonable
and so and they show a level of
experience that people have
so let's let's think about this rather
than an unstructured way where we just
give our ideas of what could go wrong
and let's actually structure it in the
context
of decision quality okay
so
we'll start with frame and the question
is does the data product decision have a
good frame
okay so we'll just start with one of
those links in the chain
and so here's some questions we could
ask so the first one is does the product
team
project team have a common purpose
and i'd say possibly
it seems like they share
the value that they want to improve
sales people's effectiveness through
smart data products i mean i i'm
inferring that but that
i'm not too worried about that one well
how about do they share
do they have a shared perspective
and i'd say not initially sharing a
perspective includes a common
understanding of the issues of various
stakeholders
and stakeholders are the people who
are affected by
an individual's decision okay so in this
case the stakeholders are not only
her the product manager but also the
engineering team
right and so at the beginning she hadn't
really considered what the data
enabled but eventually they got there
right
eventually they talked about it she gave
him space to do a study and then give
feedback
and then finally is it appropriately to
scope decision
is it big enough is it small enough well
as initially framed it's not
appropriately scoped
an email an angry email classifier is a
smart data product but it's not what the
team could do
given the time that they were given
but eventually they got there and so
um it's it's hard to give an answer
because we don't know a lot of the
backstory
of this case study which is fine uh but
it suffices to say that the project team
should test the frame
until there's agreement that it's
appropriate in other words the two of
them should say like
uh if they have any particular issues
those issues should be raised
um if they feel like the decision is
should be
uh constrained to be smaller or if it
should be expanded to be bigger
right they should talk about that until
finally they agree on
the frame being appropriate all right
so let's talk about failure modes that
could stop a product
decision from having a good frame the
first is and i see this one quite a bit
actually is that data scientists just
accept the frame they're given without
challenging it
and this would have happened had our
engineering lead
said great angry email classifier we'll
just do that
right if you'd accepted that without
saying hey we need to investigate it
that's what i'm talking about here uh
that leads to problems and so
i i sometimes see data scientists
treating requests from product
management like it's a homework problem
like it's
like it's a problem that's been given
and i just need to find the answer to it
without questioning whether or not it's
the right problem to solve
okay another problem i see sometimes is
people jump ahead to the technology
required to solve it they might say
oh you know what we've been waiting for
a chance to use
transfer learning and this is going to
be a great chance for us to use transfer
learning
we'll get started right away right
without again saying
is this the right problem to be working
the next one
is scoping the decision too narrowly or
too broadly
so an example is if the owner of the
product roadmap
expects the product expects a product
that the data just
aren't going to going to allow right so
you can imagine like
if she wanted a product that told sales
people what to do
but uh the engineers had no access to
sales call data or text data or
other sorts of conversations that
happened then you're probably not going
to be able to do that that's probably
scoped too broadly
um or likewise you can have a problem
that's scoped too narrowly where the
product team is unclear about the
decisions value and they just aim too
low because
they want to work on something they know
will be a technical success
whether or not it's a marketing success
and you need both
and finally uh the failure mode of
excluding other stakeholders frames
and i want to talk about this a little
bit right now so
a few thoughts on the frames of other
stakeholders so i'm
talking about a decision around whether
or not to pursue a data product
that's not the only kind of decision
we're faced right we face
all sorts of decisions and one of which
as data scientists
is uh for example um
what other people uh
uh what sorts of decisions other people
are making and
their frames for those decisions so we
can improve uh the project by
considering the frames of other
stakeholders like
we can think about the decisions of the
sales people the who are the users of
our data product
what do they want to inform we're giving
them a prediction what decision is that
prediction helping with
and what frame do people who decide
whether to purchase the product take so
we may be thinking about
sales people but perhaps we should be
thinking also about their managers
because maybe the managers of sales
people
both our customers but perhaps their
managers are the ones who are going to
make the purchase decisions
right we can also think about
our team's uh data product decision can
be nested within the broader
organization's decision making so we may
have internal
executives who decide about funding in
the strategic direction
and those decisions constrain the frame
of our decision so
for example would make no sense to
pursue this objection classifier
if our leadership had a stated goal of
doing voice to text transcriptions of
sales calls
and extracting information to give back
to salespeople about sales calls
right if that's the state of direction
we shouldn't be working on something
that's in conflict with that
and that's all about the frame of our
leaders and then finally
data scientists themselves have
decisions within the product decision
so once we decide yes we're going to go
after an objection classifier
our data scientists have to begin making
decisions like what sort of architecture
should i use to build it
how is this going to fit inside of our
tech stack all those kinds of things
are decisions that get made after we
make the decision about what product to
to pursue and when we make the decision
about what product to pursue we should
be
thinking about all these other kinds of
decisions how our customers are going to
use our product
how our product fits in with the broader
organization's stated goals
and whether or not our team is going to
be able to make good decisions uh around
the product decision
okay so let's move on to uh alternatives
okay so this is the second uh component
we'll talk about
and so the question is does the data
product decision have a good set of
alternatives and we can
we can test that so some questions we
should ask number one is the alternative
we're presuming pursuing feasible
i mean this is the most obvious question
right is this something we think we can
do
and in the case of our case study
at the outset no the data and the
timeline simply did not
the timeline did not support what we
needed to be able to get done
but eventually yes so our product
manager was wise enough to let
the engineering team have enough space
to study this
and eventually given that and given the
user experience research
they agreed it was pos both possible and
valuable
and then the next question is have we
considered a set of alternatives or just
one
so this is a common thing that we see as
a failure mode
in fact is that only one alternative is
considered
so initially the product manager only
considered one that she wanted an angry
email classifier but eventually they got
there
and they grew the list to two and so
there's an open question now
is this enough is two really enough
are these two particular alternatives uh
really covering the space of good
alternatives and do we have the best
alternative within that set
and i recall that one person when asking
what could go wrong in that poll
said we don't have enough options
right and so this is a classic failure
mode
and then finally are the range of
stakeholder viewpoints represented with
represented within the alternative set
so for example have we spoken to a
diverse enough set of customers
if we've spoken to just a handful of
customers
but not all of them we may release a
product that satisfies some customers
but not a broad set of customers
or if we're thinking about expanding our
customer base
to new industries are we thinking about
those new industries and how they'll
interact with our product
i mean we want to develop something
that's going to work now and in the
future not just now
and and finally does this product idea
align with the overall direction with
our business we talked about
that a little bit with framing but is
this
particular alternative that we're
pursuing is it consistent
with how our managers and executives are
thinking about the direction of business
okay so this is an important
principle and it is that the decision we
make can only be as good as our best
alternative
so if by failure of imagination or
because
uh we're too risk-averse we've left the
best alternative outside
of our frame uh then we're leaving value
on the table and we don't want to do
that we want to make sure
we have the best alternative in our set
of alternatives
so we've talked a little bit about
failure modes here but let's
just go through them quickly so here are
three kind of classic failure modes this
is not an exhaustive
lift list but it is a list that's uh
reasonable
the first is we have a product team a
project team with one or very few
alternatives we talked about that
uh the second is data scientists being
order takers so
the product manager comes in and says
make me ann and then
fill in the blank and then the data
science team just says right on
we'll just do that without questioning
anything and finally
project teams failing to have an ethical
framework for removing data product
alternatives that they should not be
considering
right so this can get people into
trouble
okay so let's move from alternatives uh
on to values and trade-offs
so here are some questions we can ask in
this case study about values and
trade-offs
and the first is are there explicit
value measures for
evaluating the alternatives in other
words do we have a number we can place
on one alternative versus another to be
able to say one is better than another
and the answer is as far as we know
these value measures are implicit we
never talk about numbers
we just talk about a successful ux study
that she brings up
and a feasible modeling task which he
brought up but there may be lots of
alternatives that meet these two
criteria so how would we choose between
them
if we had yet more alternatives on the
list
right the next one is uh are there
are the value measures appropriate and
given the project team is only
considering two alternatives and it's
clear
that one is a lot better than the other
then
using just an implicit value measure may
be sufficient you may not need
to put things into numbers because it's
pretty obvious which one you should
pursue
um but then a question comes up how
would we know if this data product were
successful we don't have any way of
measuring it
then how would we know it's successful
so i'm not saying that
every decision requires a value measure
but it's something
worth asking especially if there are
competing
things that you're trading off like the
time to market for
a particular feature you're working on
or the level of quality working on with
that feature
or the amount of cost that the product
will incur right so when you're thinking
about things like that it can be really
useful
to use numbers and then finally when
objectives conflict
is it clear how we make tradeoffs
between them
so you know feasibility of modeling
tasks and
and the results of ux study aren't
binary right
they're usually on a continuum and so if
no alternative is obviously best how do
we trade them off so for example
imagine that the
objection classifier were more feasible
but it did worse in the user experience
study
than the issue classifier which was a
little less feasible
but looked like it was more valuable to
the customer now you have two things in
conflict how do you trade those two
things off
and that's that's talking about the
clear values and trade-offs
a link of the chain okay so i want to
make
a quick run through the failure modes
that prevent clear values and trade-offs
so one is teams fail to discuss value
measures
like we want we're talking about quality
but we never have a way of measuring
quality
in the product for example uh another is
the product project team
does not know how competing competing
values should be traded off
for example model accuracy versus
development time
um a friend of mine uh john mark agusta
he likes to refer to the cult of model
accuracy
where all you do is just as a data
scientist is just try to make things
more accurate and more accurate and more
accurate
and at some point you're not you're
you're doing more harm than good because
you're delaying that particular feature
from getting into customers hands
and delivering them value okay the third
is data scientists end up sequestered
deep inside of an organization
and never actually talk with customers
and so then they're
just relegated to looking at clicks or
other such measures
that lose the narrative about how the
product is being used and what customers
care about
and i think both are important and then
finally data scientists being data
driven yet blind to value
so you really to to really empathize
with your customer you need to
understand what your customer cares
about
and be driven by what they value
uh whereas uh being data driven is a
good
thing also being values driven is a good
thing and frankly if i had to choose
between the two i would lean
a little more betw toward being value
driven even being data-driven
okay so i'd like to make a quick note on
alternatives and trade-offs
or you could call tradeoffs values how
you value things
um and that is that data scientists and
decision professionals tend to think
and and executives tend to think in
different directions so we have
a venn diagram here on the left we have
what is possible with the data
and on the right we have what is
valuable to the user or the decision
maker
right what is possible with the data on
the left what is valuable to the user on
the right
and really you could think about these
two sets as
the the set of things on the left that
are technically feasible
that that that define technical success
and the set of things on the right are
the things that
define marketing success okay
you want to work as engineers working on
data products you want to work
on the intersection between these two
sets you want to deliver valuable data
products
right and so where do you start well
um decision makers executives decision
professionals tend to think from right
to left
they tend to as the mckinsey report
quote
says they tend to work business backward
and not data forward
right they start with what's valuable
from a business standpoint and then see
whether or not the data can support that
and you think okay that that that makes
sense but actually data scientists tend
to think in the other direction
so they think first what's possible with
the data and then what's valuable to the
decision maker
and here's a nice quote by a nobel prize
winning uh economist
named robert schiller and he says some
of the best theorizing comes
after collecting data because when you
become because then you become aware of
another reality
and if i can reinterpret that from a
decision frame i could say
look once i look at the data it may
uncover new alternatives that i had
never considered before because
i just wasn't aware that they'd be a
possibility
right so there are two different ways to
think about this
and if stuart if you can queue up the
poll question number four
and here's poll question number four
what is the best way to think
should you start a with what is possible
with the data
or should be should you start with what
is valuable to decision maker
so if we could just take about 15
seconds and just
give your opinion on this choose a or b
and click submit
so again just to let you remember what
the venn diagram was
on the left was starting with the data
and
was working with what was feasible with
the data on the right is working about
with what's valuable to the decision
maker and the intersection
is where data products should reside and
the question is do you start
with the data or do you start with
what's valuable to the decision maker
should be values focused first or
data-driven
and oh i'm a bit surprised so
the winner is by about almost a two to
one margin is starting with what's
valuable to the decision maker and you
surprised me
and my answer to this is my particular
answer
this would have been my answer in the
past i think
um and now that i've i've been working
um you know building models working
as a machine learning engineer working
with data i actually
have a new opinion and my opinion is
this that
um you you really want both
right and and i'm not trying to get
around this question i really mean this
so like when as a data scientist you
should be familiar with your data you
should be deep
have a deep understanding of what's
available but at the same time
you should also have a certain
understanding of what's valuable to your
customers
so you should be constantly interacting
with customers as much as you can
right be that listening in on user
surveys
or talking to people that use the
product
because what that does is it makes you
more sensitive
as you're looking through the data as to
what new alternatives might be
good ones right and likewise i think
from the product management side
i think that they should be to a certain
degree familiar with the data
right and and for the same reason they
should have a sense for what's feasible
and what's not feasible
and the way we've done this with our
product managers is we've actually had
them
get involved with labeling data right
so we we have uh data that we want to
um use for training in a model and that
data need
those data for supervised learning need
to be uh
they need to be labeled and so we
actually have our product managers spend
some time
labeling a few hundred examples and this
does a world of good it gives them a
sense of what's out there
it makes things less abstract for them
and on the other side
we have been having our data scientists
sit in on customer interviews
that our ux team conducts so they can
hear first person from users of the
product
about what's important to them so i
think there's
uh there's value in understanding both
sides
and kind of iterating between the two
okay
so what are some failure modes that
can i'm going to skip ahead to
information and logic links and kind of
do them together in the interest of time
so for information failures some failure
modes we might see there
are user studies that reflect the
present world but not the future
someone i know was working on trends
sort of fashion trends and their
company wanted to to use user studies
today
uh to see whether or not a product
should should pursue one direction or
another
and her argument was look you're talking
about today
but people's tastes change according to
fashion what we we shouldn't be talking
with users for this we should be talking
with
trendsetters experts and how trends
change right
so that's one way uh for an information
failure is that you don't think about
uh i guess um in north america you'd
call that skating to where the puck will
be not to where it is
um the second one is seeking
new data when it won't change a decision
so from an organizational standpoint
as soon as you have enough data to make
a decision getting more is not going to
be helpful
and it's not valuable it's just going to
slow things down so this is a classic
information failure
and then finally not recognizing an
undesirable type of bias in the
trainings
in the training data okay and then for
failures of logic
uh there's one main failure of logic
which is lacking some coherent mains
means of combining information and
trade-offs
to identify the best alternative in the
set of alternatives you have that's it
okay so uh let's move toward poll
question
number five and we will um
do this via the chat window once again
and the question is does our team have
commitment to action
and why why not
so go ahead and open
oh excuse me not
not the chat window sorry stuart can you
can you bring up the uh
polling window again i i
had forgotten that this was a multiple
choice
thank you so let's just take
30 seconds to fill this in and so
does the team have commitment to action
why or why not answer a says
yes once the objection classifier is on
the product roadmap
we know they have commitment to action
answer b says yes
because the product manager and data
scientists lead verbally agree
and then answer c says no because they
have not yet worked out a project plan
so let's take just a few more seconds
to enter into this poll
okay stuart maybe let's close it in
about a few more seconds
okay so the winner
is looks like at c
they don't have commitment action
because they have not yet worked out a
project plan
okay and so that's a close second
is a which is yes once the objective
objection classifier is on the product
roadmap
and i think that my answer to this is
i think probably the best answer is is a
um but there is still room for
uh failure modes but at least in our
organization once a product is on the
roadmap
uh it signifies that uh
they're like it's acceptable for people
to begin
applying resources to that project so
simply
being on the product product roadmap is
a strong indicator that
that a particular data product decision
for in our case
um has commitment to action but there
are still potential failure modes
so uh so let's let's talk about
uh whether or not the team has
commitment to action
so one question for knowing is does the
team
or decision maker allocate enough
resources to implement the decision
and in the case study the indicators of
commitment
are that the data science team assigns
sufficient people to the product or
starting the project and the project
manager gets it on the product roadmap
so that seems reasonable um
we don't know whether or not the data
science team actually assigns sufficient
people
that's left to our imagination the
second one is
given the product meets the minimum
requirements does the product manager
green light the feature to be added to a
generally available software release
so in other words if the team succeeds
and the market doesn't shift
does the feature go ga so these are two
kind of indicators that there is
commitment to action
that second one is not terribly useful
because we won't know it until after
the decision was taken right the first
one is something we will know
okay so failure modes for commitment to
action
the first is the chosen project is
starved for resources
right so everybody says yeah great let's
pursue this objection classifier but
then
they can't find anybody to work on it
the second one
and all occasionally i've occasionally
seen this in my career
where a particular project
is not given enough official support to
where
resources can be applied to it but some
kind of middle level manager
it's a pet project for them and so they
unofficially
carve out some time for people on their
team to work on it a so-called skunk
works
where you have this team in secret
working on some project idea
rather than being on the official
project roadmap well to me when that
happens that suggests that there was
never any
true commitment organizationally to
pursue this project
and then finally and again these failure
mode lists are not exhausted these are
just examples
but finally important stakeholders fail
to get behind the project for example
um the app team doesn't have the
objection feature on the roadmap so
all the backend teams are are ready to
go they're fully resourced
they are they have what they need to
to deliver their part of the product but
then no one
on the ui and no one on the receiving
end from the front end
teams is available to help put this
thing into production
right so that's another example of of a
lack of organizational commitment
okay so let's summarize what we talked
about today
i want to hit the high points so the
first one is
people recognize how valuable data is
clearly
the people in the seminar must also or
else you probably wouldn't be here
um and the second thing is in the
context of prediction
data gets its value from the decisions
it informs
i think this is really important and
then the third thing is
data scientists should have a framework
for thinking and communicating about
decisions
and i posit that this decision quality
framework is the right one
to use it's a very useful framework and
it comes from the field of decision
analysis
and then finally and i want to spend a
little time on this
this particular framework for decision
quality can help data scientists avoid
failure modes that you
see commonly in this field and they can
help by one
communicating more clearly with their
stakeholders product managers you can
imagine
if a product manager is working with
this
language with this framework and an
engineer is working with this framework
now you can say things like
i want to challenge your frame on this
particular decision
or have we considered this other
alternative
or do we really know how to trade off
these two
competing factors right or how do we
know that we have commitment
uh for this particular decision that
we're taking right
so it gives you a language to use
secondly
it gives space to challenge ill-framed
product ideas
so if we agree that we're working with
this decision quality framework
it kind of makes it okay to say you know
what i don't agree with your frame
or can you help me understand your frame
better right
third it helps you better empathize with
the users of your models
right so if you're taking if you have
this decision framework you can think
about the decisions not only that
you are making that your organization is
making but also that the users of your
predictions are making
right and when you do that you can think
about what they value you can talk to
them and immediately when you talk start
talking to someone about what they value
how they trade things off you better
empathize with them which makes
you better at designing products that
they will like
and then finally having a framework can
help you more explicitly consider
ethics in the products so uh if you have
a specific
organizational ethic around doing
something or not doing something
uh especially if it's not doing
something then that any alternative that
does that thing should be excluded
immediately
then you don't have to spend any more
time on it right
so these are just some examples of how
this framework can be
helpful for data scientists so
with that i want to leave you with a
handful of resources
uh the first of which is a book
on this subject it's a very readable
book uh it's called decision quality
it's it's written from a more broad
standpoint it's not in the context
of data science it's just in the context
of decision quality it's called value
creation
from better business decisions and this
is by carl spetzler and
uh hannah winter and jennifer meyer this
was written just a few years ago
um it's a nice very accessible book
short book uh the next one is called the
foundations of decision analysis this is
by my phd advisor ronald a howard
and ali abbas who's a professor at usc
um and this is a textbook it's sort of a
upper division early graduate school
textbook on decision analysis
so if you want to get into kind of more
of the details around that i recommend
this book
the next one is called value focused
thinking a path to creative decision
making and this is by
uh professor ralph keaney and in this he
argues for
starting with value right so starting
with what
you care about when thinking about a
decision and allowing that to help you
come up with new and creative
alternatives so it's very much
uh going right to left on that venn
diagram we talked about so it's an
argument for that
uh and then we have the handbook of
decision analysis and this is sort of a
professional
professional's handbook and it's for
kind of consultants
and decision professionals if people are
interested in that as a field
this is a nice handbook and then finally
i can point you to a youtube video of a
panel discussion that i hosted
last year with a set of data scientists
which is called
bringing out the decision analyst and
the data scientists
okay with that stuart i am wrapped up
so uh shall we begin our q a session
yes we shall um and we have a few
questions that came in through our
youtube live
um one of which is i'm in chemical
engineering how can i apply it
this in my field
uh if you're in chemical engineering
[Music]
this field has been applied more readily
to that discipline i would say than it
has
to data science at least to this point
now
frankly every discipline makes decisions
so it's applicable in any discipline
um but there is a
rich set of literature at least in the
oil and gas and energy industry
um there's one book by patrick leach
called uh just give me the number
which i think is a really interesting uh
take and it's
it's it's written from an oil and gas
perspective uh
and i think it would be applicable to
chemical processing as well
so anytime you face like a design
decision or process change decision
or anything like that i think that you
can use this same framework
like what do we care about what are we
trading off there may be a safety versus
dollar trade-off
that you want to make explicit uh what
alternatives are we considered
are we considering etc so
i think it's very applicable in chemical
um one user asks
what exactly do you mean by trade-offs
uh yes so uh
you can think about
different attributes that alternatives
have
right so you can be
making a decision about uh
like let's let's let's move it beyond
data science let's let's say like
it's a decision about whether or not to
manufacture a good in-house
or whether or not to purchase that good
from
an oem supplier okay so
you might say okay well
we could just look at the dollars like
they'll charge us x dollars if we make
it in-house it'll cost
y dollars okay but there's other things
as well
so for example you no longer control the
quality if someone else is making it
and so how do you trade that off with
dollars how do you
how do you know how much you're willing
to give in terms of
quality performance from this oem
supplier
versus the amount of money that you
might save by going with them right
and also it might be that uh working
with that oem supplier
uh adds time in your supply chain and so
what's that worth to you as well
right so you need a way when you have
competing values
a way to be able to say which one is
better than the other
that's all trade-offs is
um the last two questions we're going to
take both relate
to examples from industry one
user asks can we use preventive
analytics and health care
um to prevent getting disease
with descriptive and predictive
analytics
okay can we use preventive analytics and
healthcare
uh i think what he's asking is what is
can we use
descriptive and predictive analytics and
healthcare as a
major yes so when i think about
preventive
analytics what i'm thinking about is um
i'm not i'm not familiar with the term
but if i but if i unpack the words i
think
okay you're making an intervention right
like you're doing something
which means you're making an action
which means you're making a decision so
preventive analytics might be using
analytics to
perhaps uh make a policy decision right
um so yes of course and
that should be done right like when
people are thinking about for example
covet in the u.s
and they're thinking about decisions
around
whether or not i don't know to mandate
mask wearing in a particular
community right so they could
look at what what do the data say
and given that which alternative would
work best
and so i think descriptive analytics
fit under the information
link of the chain and when you start
talking about preventive
now you're talking about the
alternatives link of the chain because
you're taking an action
so they it all fits it all fits there's
i think
a decision analyst would not make those
distinctions would you they would just
say
what data do we have what then maybe
they build a probabilistic model out of
that data
and then given what that model says and
the very various actions we can take
and the response uh the model response
of those actions then what should we do
that's how i'd answer that
um i have a question from a ceo
who is learning data science he asked
how will this help support executive
support systems
yeah um this is
a question i'm not surprised to get this
question i've heard it before
and um you know
if you talk about and this is maybe kind
of the more classic data science
um or or i shouldn't say more classic
maybe the
the the part of data science that does
things like visualization
dashboarding etc oftentimes those are
the things that make their way up to the
c-suite
and uh those kinds of things as a ceo
are
part of your information list so uh
so you you need to be thinking i think
on a regular basis what decisions are
are we facing is our company facing and
then
given those decisions and given what we
care about what sorts of
what sort of information will help
inform those things and then working
with your teams
to get data to support that information
i think so that's the way i think about
it uh that's not
um to say that people coming within the
organization
bringing results of models is also not
important in fact
uh when i was doing strategy consulting
that's pretty much what we did
we worked with ceos to frame their
decisions
um and then we built models
and worked with this is our data
analytic teams
to inform those models and then came
back to the ceo
with the results of those models saying
hey if you choose a
here's your possible range of outcomes
here's a probability distribution of
your outcomes
if you choose b here's a probability
distribution of your outcomes
and then the ceo would test and maybe
poke holes in the analysis and we'd go
back and run it again
and come back and make arguments or not
make arguments we would present the
results
and let the data make the arguments
themselves so
i hope that answers the question but
yeah and then the quest the i think the
last question we can take
since we're over time um is
how can data science be used in
agriculture
animal husbandry dairy
well um if you're asking that question i
would say
this might be a case where you want to
start with values
right you want to start with what do you
care about
and think about what actions you can
take
to get more of what you care about right
so
in the field of of agriculture you may
be facing decisions about
how and when to apply fertilizer how
much to apply
etc so this is a decision you might
declare
and you may have a bunch of different
alternatives for how best to do it
perhaps based on um studies
that support those things and then you
may need data to be able to do it like
maybe
uh i've i've heard a lot of of uh
like drone imagery being used
in agricultural fields to to understand
kind of like
uh the response of crops to various
treatments
and so um you can see how these things
all tie together like
we have a bunch of different
alternatives about how uh
we can um work
uh with our particular field and then we
have different data sources that can
help inform it
we can apply a particular treatment and
then we can get feedback on that
treatment
and use that to make decisions about a
different field etc
so i think it again decision making
pervades human life so there's no field
that it does not but this
framework does not apply to you in the
abstract so i think it applies to
anything
and i think that's a great note for us
to finish on
thank you very much brad thank you
stuart thanks for the opportunity
enjoyed it thanks everyone for all of
your feedback and energy
yeah and if you go ahead and share the
next
slide we have an upcoming webinar
next tuesday another simple learn
webinar
and this one is a career oriented
especially oriented towards new grads
expert tips for a successful career
redefining future readiness for the
modern graduate and this is
the vice chancellor of the srm institute
of science and technology
dr sandeep sinchetti
so we hope you will join us for that
webinar
and we hope that you have found today's
webinar useful
and you can connect to simplylearn using
our various
uh social media handles i think that's
on the next library
and we are on facebook twitter and
linkedin
and brad people can connect with you on
linkedin yes
yes wonderful so
um again that concludes our webinar
today we hope to see you at the next one
i want to thank brad powley again for
giving us these insights into
decision analysis and how it makes you a
better data scientist
and um i'd like to ask everyone at this
point to please
log off of webex there will be a survey
that pops up
and if you can take a couple moments to
answer those survey questions that will
be helpful
thank you again goodbye everyone
[Music]
you